you know I've done a lot of videos on
certain indicators from someone's body
whether their skin or looking at their
eyes or their lips to determine what's
going on on the inside well today we're
going to talk about
the relationship between someone's skin
and diabetes their skin reveals a lot at
the end of this video you'll be able to
glance over at someone look at their
skin
and pretty much know if they have
diabetes or not and of course you can
apply this to yourself if you have any
of these skin problems I'm going to tell
you what to do but here's the big
problem I see with diabetes in general
okay
medicine's goal is to help manage and
regulate blood sugars so you are given
certain medications to help normalize
your blood sugar well pretty much
problem solved if we could just manage
your blood sugars you'll be okay but my
question is like what do you mean manage
blood sugars well you're lowering the
blood sugars to a normal level right
just like you would do with high blood
pressure and medication but the question
I have is
where is this sugar going that you're
managing or you're lowering is it
evaporating or is it just going from one
place to another and the answer is it's
going from one place to another it's
going from your blood
to other parts of your body like your
liver like your organs it's being
converted to fat as a fatty liver so
it's not correcting anything it's just
transferring one problem to another
problem so there's two main issues with
diabetes in relationship to your skin
one problem with the high blood glucose
directly affecting your skin or even
indirectly and then you have other
problems related to the hormone that is
involved with diabetes called insulin so
let's start with the insulin part first
insulin is a glucose lowering hormone
okay
when you have high blood glucose you
also will have at least initially a very
high level of insulin to counter this
blood glucose level
not to mention the body will start to
develop insulin resistance which is
going to send information back to the
pancreas saying we need to increase more
insulin to fight or penetrate this
resistance with diabetes and
pre-diabetes you usually always have a
higher level of insulin it's really
tested mainly the focus in the blood
glucose okay but if they were to test
someone's insulin it would be higher
until the point where the pancreas
become so exhausted that it can't output
insulin and then it starts going down at
that point the person needs to start
taking insulin unfortunately but that's
a different subject so when we have
higher levels of insulin and insulin
resistance
one common uh symptom of that related to
the skin it's called acanthosis
negrokans This is actually
one of the common symptoms of insulin
resistance and it's a situation where
your skin is darkening it's looking
Tanner and it almost has a velvet
texture to it it mainly accumulates in
the different folds of the body armpits
the side of the neck the back of the
neck the different folds like on the
crease in your elbow and this is
occurring because of a cell called the
melanocyte which makes melanin which is
the pigment of someone's skin insulin
resistance causes an overproduction
of this cell okay so that's the first
skin problem the Second Skin problem I'm
going to talk about related to insulin
is the skin tags so insulin is an
anabolic hormone and when you produce
too much insulin okay it makes things
grow it makes these mini tumors and so a
skin tag is a benign growth and so
that's the connection to a skin tag we
have increased insulin increase growth
and by the way if you want to know how
to get rid of skin tags pretty fast I'll
put a link down below alright the next
skin problem is called digital sclerosis
and this is just a skin condition where
your skin is thicker okay the texture is
rough and you probably have some dryness
you have some flakiness and this is also
coming from elevated insulin in your
blood and so your skin cells have these
little cells called keratinocytes so
insulin affects these cells it makes
them grow in an abnormal way giving you
a thicker or rougher skin and I would
also venture to say that it's probably
also involved in corns like having a
corn on your skin all right the next
condition that's affected by insulin is
just acne when you have increased
insulin and this especially occurs in
females okay especially with polycystic
ovarian syndrome where you have this
high level of Androgen which is
affecting the sebaceous plan of the oil
gland of the skin increasing risk of
getting acne
so what's behind an elevated Androgen is
an elevated insulin so PCOS is really an
elevation of insulin causing the
elevation of Androgen and acne is just
one of the symptoms now another thing
about insulin resistance and blood
sugars as well
is what it can do to the immune system
it can lower the person's immune system
increasing the risk for infections and
certain type of bacterial infections can
lead to cysts like a Baker cyst for
example and I've noticed in practice a
very high percentage of people who have
Baker cyst are also diabetics and so
this involves the relationship between
what blood sugar does to your immune
system now let's just talk about blood
glucose level when the blood glucose
level goes high you can develop a lot of
problems with circulation to the skin
okay and so when the tiny capillaries
are affected in the lower part of your
legs for example you can develop these
little red or purple dots or blotches
which is called particular or purpura so
particular are the real small little red
purple dots and purpura are the larger
ones
but this is a problem with circulation
because the capillary beds are being
destroyed
and you're getting this leaking blood
into the tissue so you usually see this
in the lower legs of diabetics where
they have all these different
um black and blue marks it looks like
there's bruised but that's just really
coming because the high level of glucose
really destroys both the micro
circulation okay the tiny capillaries as
well as the macro circulations your
blood vessels in general so you're
losing oxygen and blood flow to the
tissues starting with the peripheral
part of the body first like it happens
in the feet and then the lower ankles so
that leads us to the next condition
which is gangrene which your feet in
your toes start to turn different colors
like green black brown blue this is a
severe diabetic complication from just
basically causing your tissues to die
okay and then it they start amputating
your foot and it starts to spread up
higher and higher and higher too late
could end up amputating the entire leg
and a certain type of gangrene called
wet gangrene has an infection component
to it as well so now we have an
infection all because of loss of blood
flow because the blood glucose is just
too high now you can also get leg
ulcers or ulcers in the foot from being
a diabetic and this too is caused from
poor circulation and an infection
because the immune system is inhibited
when you have this condition another
condition that you can easily observe a
blood sugar problem not just diabetes or
again pre-diabetes but even the
condition that happens before that which
is insulin resistance if you look at the
person's eyes they look swollen and
puffy and red I'm talking about the
eyelids and I had a bit of this long ago
and I did not have a clue of where that
was coming from you know the eyelids if
they're puffy could be a kidney problem
but what is the number one cause of
kidney failure it's diabetes so with
diabetes and pre-diabetes you have a lot
of fluid retention that shows up in the
eyes it can also show up in the lower
legs and feet so I just gave you quite a
few different skin conditions related to
both blood sugars and Insulin but my
question always comes down to boy there
is so much
focus on treating this symptom in
diagnosing these conditions but very
little energy or focus on treating the
diabetes itself the high blood glucose
and what causes that so I don't know
it's just it's wild to me that this
obvious problem of consuming too much
sugar and carbs
is not really dealt with or focused on
it's just it blows my mind but the more
you think about it it really relates to
medication there's a lot of money
involved in this condition and if it
really was that easy there would be
entire industries that would not make
nearly as much money both on the
medication end and then also here on the
food end as well so if you want to see
some dramatic changes in your skin if
you have diabetes this is what I would
do immediately okay I would get on a low
carb diet number one I would start doing
intermittent fasting both of those
actions right there will create a
significant difference pretty quickly I
would also start consuming about a
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar in my
water a few times a day apple cider
vinegar has a potent effect on helping
someone with blood sugar issues and
making insulin more sensitive and in the
correction of this insulin resistance
problem and the next thing I would do is
take probably one of the most effective
herbal versions of Metformin like a
natural version of Metformin that you
can take it's well studied and it's
called berberine okay now berberine in a
study that I'm going to post down below
had identical effects
on regulating one's blood sugars if you
compare to metformin but without side
effects and it showed even better
effects on cholesterol regulation
triglycerol regulation improvements in a
fatty liver decrease problems related to
your heart decrease inflammation as well
as Improvement in skin conditions
related to diabetes like acne and
inflammation and it's cheaper and has
less side effects so keto intermittent
fasting apple cider vinegar and
berberine now since berberine is such a
heavy hitter when we're dealing with
blood sugars if you haven't seen my
video on berberine directly I put it up
right here check it out